bryce harper's been waiting to do this
for a long time
this year getting a chance to do it in
front of a handful of the 8 800 expected
to be here this afternoon here's ronaldo
lacuna junior
14 home runs a season ago 29 runs batted
in in the first pitch of the season
is hit in the air to left field towering
shot playable for mccutchen
he and hasley are there and hazley makes
the call
and the catch one pitch one
set aside max you know great year last
year a couple things
only allowed two home runs last year i
thought that was huge and last year
right he's hit 209 off
him lefty said 220. the first pitch is
lying to right field that's it for a
base hit
that andrew mccutchen is aboard to begin
the bottom of the first
yeah you got a couple runners on both
guys run well and
get a ball in the gap here phil's could
go up two nothing or
launch one here three nothing would go a
long way in this ball game that ball of
the dirt and it hit him
and the bases are loaded
you know i'm alec bone right now ben you
know he's struggling with his off-speed
pitches
looked dead red first pitch like andrew
did try to put a good swing on and put
your team
up the high in the air to left field
it's not
deep tagging from third is mccutchen
ozuna is under comes running in the
throw to the plate
sails to the left and it is not in time
a run scores the other runners move up
a sacrifice fly the fills are on top
one to nothing here's austin reilly who
a season ago had eight home runs
27 runs batted in
curveball rolled up the third base line
charging his bone this is where he's
improved he flips it to first dug out by
hoskins
well he improves and going in to get the
baseball
and then rhys hoskins improves the play
by picking it
on one hop and acuna bats
with two outs his 30th pitch is whacked
inside the bag fair and down
the left field line it hits right off
the point of the stands
and ronald lacuna junior's first hit of
the season is a stand-up double with two
outs
traditionally aaron like a lot of good
pitchers
buckles down with rudders in scoring
position but ben is right
the guy on deck is not the one you want
to face
rolls over to the right side and gene
segura is there
there's a good hook max freight has his
third strikeout and two in a row now
three strikeouts for freed and rhys
hoskins is coming up
curveball pulled that's a fair ball down
the left field line slowly going toward
the corner
hoskins on his way to second he'll get
their standing
his first hit of the season and the
phillies have a one-out double here in
the
bottom of the third price was at 233
with runners in scoring position a
season ago
that one's off the end of the bat flares
in the right center field to base it
reece had to hold up so he'll stop at
third
bryce may have broken his back but the
phillies have first and third with one
out here in the third inning
you got a fourth hitter coming up your
fifth hitter coming up
this is their job to drive in runs with
with the
runners on third with less than two outs
[Applause]
oh man it looked like he got his hand in
there
a run scores it's two nothing right now
two outs
but i'm sure the phillies will take a
look at this one but that's something in
your head you have to know that bryce is
aggressive sometimes overly aggressive
oh they called him out
riley is creeping into third aaron
struck out his first plate appearance
this one's putted toward freeman he's
going to go to second and it goes into
center fields
everybody is safe
you want to get hoskins because harper's
on deck
and a swing and a miss max needed that
2-2 pitch swing and a mess he threw him
another change up
and he deceived him five strikeouts
ground ball right side and segura has
got it throws to first hitting is over
five
shutout innings so far for aranola
that's big run to cut off freya muto at
second with
one out and strike three that's a big
yellow hammer curveball right there
best of the game for freed who has
struck out
seven men
and he struck him out again gregorius
has the hat trick eight strikeouts for
max freed
freddy smoked the ball to center field
his last time up he's also bounced out
to first as we told you he's been a
philly killer the last couple of years
freddie a bouncing ball right side
hoskins botches that
nola botches the throw freddy's on his
way to second acuna's on his way to
third
so our first chance to talk about a big
problem for the phillies last year it
was their defense
so ozuna's one for two he has singled
and struck out and a live drive caught
by alec ball
jumping high in the air over at third
base two away
oh to be six five amen to that
that was trouble once it left the bat
yeah that is as good as it's going to
get and you know two runs are going to
score there
ozuna's going to be on second base and
it's been no secret how nola's going
after darno today lot of fastballs
and a cold strike three 91 on the
outside
part of the plate darneau goes down
looking
the side is retired a little defense
from bowm
and christian poche the final seventh
inning hope
breaks his bat and shoots one down the
left field line into the corner
mccutchen will dig that out
and pache will stand at second with a
two-out double
and now the braves will have a chance to
go to their bench and get the game
tied and it'll be the kung fu panda
pablo sandoval getting the call
[Applause]
and a drive hammer deep right field it's
a pitch hit home run
for pablo sandoval game is tied
two two on an 02 pitch
tries to come fastball in and really or
trying to go fastball the way
pulled this on the inner part of the
zone and pablo hammered it
and on a day jeff where erin nola threw
85 pitches
only one is one he wants back
the base runners freeman at third
darneau at second riley at first
pache doubled his last time up
swag gonna miss a hundred miles an hour
and the side is retired he strikes out
three
serves it out towards shallow left
center field d.d gregorius is there oh
what a play
he falls to his backside and reels it in
fighting the wind the entire time
what a route what a grab and what a way
to end
the top of the ninth inning the runner
at second base is the guy that made the
last out in the previous hitting so it's
ozzy all these in this case
as freddie hits this one to the right
side that'll be a productive out
runner is 90 feet away for atlanta and
ozzie albees who could put the braves in
front
on the hands looped out to center field
roman quinn comes in all these tanks at
third quinn's got it all these is coming
home
he hesitated for a moment to throw to
the plate he is
[Applause]
he is on a mission to do some damage
harper's at third that's what matters
gregorius at first
over toward third and again ahead of
riley down the left field line
harper scores easily gene segora
was a man on a mission and the mission
was
victory and the phillies have won on
opening day
in the bottom of the 10th inning three
to two
let the season begin
[Music]